prix ultra violets devenu bcbg ysabelle
dufresne extrême des amis de warhol nazg
rock'n'roll
ysabelle dufresne bonsoir j'ai fait une
grande découverte en lisant son livre
c'est que parmi les superstars qui
entoure et andy warhol mais y avait une
française et c'était toi
alors au départ tu fais partie d'une
bonne bourgeoisie grenobloise quoi des
gens plutôt riche il faisait quoi
oh mon père était ingénieur pas ce qu'on
peut appeler industriels
c'est une enfance assez difficile malgré
tout c'est à dire la petite fille un peu
sauvage comme ça au milieu d'une famille
bourgeoise et était dans une sorte de
couvents on peut dire non d'un couvent à
l'autre parce qu'on m'a jetée d'une
porte à l'autre
et chaque fois je me rebelle est
d'avantagé et l'amour ça s'est mal
terminée maison correction va exercice
situé d'exorciser fourni on y viendra
pas ce qu'est la faim julie d une sorte
d'exorcisme et j'étais réellement
exorciser ses rangs enfin à exorciser
avec leur propre terme c'est à dire
qu'on vous met l'eau bénie il ya une
prière spéciale aura fait par un prêtre
je sais pas comment se passent les
autres exercices
en tout cas ça n'a pas marché où j'ai
prétendu téva les marchés pas tarder à
l'air d'avoir su emballer la suite du
regain de une première expérience
sexuelle ac c'est difficile c'était
presque un viol d'une certaine façon tu
racontes savant dans le bouquin enfin
sexuellement ça tape à bloquer pour la
suite
non peut-être débloquer peut-être au
débloquer peut-être un peu dur mais sa
part setha pas réellement bloqué on sait
on si jamais ce que ça fait c'est très
difficile d'établir les causes et les
effets peut-être que à ce moment là on
perd un certain respect de la chose ou
alors on tourbillon très difficile de
savoir
il faut je crois 50 ans pour aider à
tirer les conclusions
leur un jour des parents décident
d'envoyer en revue et ça ta soeur habite
est en fait tu crois que tu vas tu joues
pas tu ranges et les voitures en
arrivant là bas mais c'est terrible ce
qui arrive là bas puis maintenant
vie c'est conquérir le monde de l'art tu
deviens copines ou amis ou amants avec
des alliés enfin manque pas vraiment
parce qu'un jour et avec lui alors il
caresse avec une langue où ce modèle
c'était sa méthode d'alien de faire
l'amour ouais c'est jamais allé plus
loin
non avec dalil s'est jamais de
pénétration avec eto'o d'imagination
très vite dalit présente à warhol qui à
l'époque est inconnu aux pleurs mais
tout de suite j'ai été fasciné par le
caractère parce que c'était un homme
vraiment un espèce d'extra terrestres il
ne parlait pas comme les autres aboli
par les appels ou s'il parlait il avait
une espèce de voix de ventriloque et
tout ce qu'il disait était tellement à
la fois génial ou india pti comparons
savez jamais qui s'était d'ailleurs par
warhol c'est un paradoxe extraordinaire
leur première rencontre avec warhol tu
te saute dessus et quand même un peu
enfin comme on dit vulgairement un peu
s'auto pas froid que les choses dessus
tout c'était pour découvrir quel était
cet homme aussi vraiment c'était un
homme d'ailleurs l'expérience a été
assez
enfin sidérant dans ce sens que comme je
le raconte que son corps et d'effroi et
devenait de plus en plus glacial enfin
c'est juste un repas s'est libéré de toi
complètement et à marseille quand même
il s'est d'abord refroidi énormément
j'ai cru qu'ils allaient de tourner à la
glace il a perdu un peu super u est la
plus en plus apaisé qui quand même resté
accroché par un bouton pression et lui
étaient imprégnés d'entrain ce n'est
quand même pas un homme ordinaire en
fait devenu une superstar de la factory
steak et les autres à l'époque les
vivats y avait john foss
il y avait un groupe super star or kiev
et brigitte jean paul beugnot oui qui
était la fille de brigitte beuls et de
monsieur berline qui était le président
de la société un str et avait eu une
année je venais mort c'est l'étape
principale qui avait quelques-uns aussi
toi on a décidé encore départ fut sais
pas comment s'appelait en fait hésiter
il y avait polyester qu'il y avait une
autre dame et ultraviolets pourquoi vous
avez choisi le violet avec warhol
je trouvais que c'était beaucoup plus
futuriste y beaucoup plus original
beaucoup plus féminin ultra c'est mieux
que maria sofia
et violet c'était très artistique la
couleur et que j'ai toujours été un peu
au delà ultra but et ça veut dire
au delà de spect la lumière
cette correspondance est bien à partir
de là c'était ali en violet comme ce
soir enfin arrive peut-être des tenues
un peu différents continents c'était
beaucoup plus violent et les choix et
violées les atouts et les lèvres tu
avais dans ton sac
c'est un petit morceau de betteraves
donc toujours m'habitera tu l'as
toujours c'est pas ça là non c'est vrai
que moi j'ai lu un truc quand ton
bouquin qui m'a complètement fasciné cqp
mettez à la droite de warhol comme ça
sur les photos dans la légende des
photos dans les journaux ton nom venait
avant celui tout le monde sait bien que
si j'ai jamais pensé la factory tu auras
tu dois effectivement un récit
connaissent à clécy quotidien la factory
il ya d'abord le sexe alors
l'homosexualité à tout crin 1
c'est ça ma choquer la petite française
que tu étais non pas parce que c'est
d'abord une époque de révolution aux
états unis et je suis parti pour ça un
peu donc c'était tout à fait normal
et à l'époque les homosexuels c'était
parfait car ils vous dérangez pas il ne
vous en france aux français pas donc
c'est non souhaité jeudi assez naïve
quand même c'est bizarre un mélange
il m'a fallu plusieurs années on vous
moins un an pour me rendre
c'est vraiment moi sexuelle c'est
bizarre non pourtant il ce n'est pas oui
m'enfin on se rend compte qu'il était
peut-être que ça
on y avait au mot sexualité
sadomasochisme bondage sans arrêt en fin
d'année et puis alors départ tout de
formidables sans arrêt dans les labo
photo et auquel warhol participait pas
d'ailleurs parce qu'un jour tu cite une
phrase en tongs ou qu'un puits seront
dean qui dit on la vire est là partout
parce que vraiment il faisait rien quoi
non mais les peintres par définition
sont des voyeurs c'est l'oeil qui est
l'organe leur diplôme au regard d ivoire
rôle d'ailleurs à bord qu'on touche et 6
mai vont toucher enfin le bras même sens
jacques s ils étaient exposés ceux qui
se bougent et tout de suite le gall
avait très peur des rapports humains je
crois est pensé que c'était une perte de
temps
parce que pour ce qu'il voulait faire ce
qui l'intéressé c'est de faire sa marque
sur la culture américaine
les rapports ça prend un temps fou il
est arrivé il ya même de la zoophilie un
moment ils jettent tout sur un cheval
oui pour associer aussi pour le besoin
du film dans les films il fallait un peu
se dépasser il fallait comme il n'est
pas d'histoire tout était improvisé il
fallait ça de plus en plus de plus en
plus fort la drogue oui mais ça dans les
années 60 c'était devenu d'abord c'est
une longue histoire la drogue a toujours
existé non moi j'ai eu très très peur de
la drogue
aboudou un gâteau avec dalida pas
complètement mais tu dis pas que cela -
non j'ai perdu mon sac j'ai perdu mes
clés je me suis dit c'est pas pourquoi
son côté bourgeois en persan ça on a
besoin de ces clés pour tricher sur les
actions alors au milieu de tout ça ou
warhol quand même du travail parce que
mon mariage iris monde jour et nuit ils
ont envahi tout le monde alors là la
boîte de soupe campbell s'est quittés a
eu l'idée parce que là les grandes
discussions là-dessus pour savoir qui
est ce qui éviterait de se détacher en
plein air le marcel duchamp bâtiment où
il apprit importe pourtant déjà le bon
sens doit rôle sort du champ droit
mais quand même voir
le conduisait toujours son pôle dit paul
et demandé à tout le monde qu est ce que
je dois faire
dites moi qu'est ce que je dois pas très
intelligent et alors si la majorité des
gens lui disaient niveau des boîtes de
conserves c'est ce qu'il a fait si trois
personnes le disait ton portrait il ne
faisait pas il voulait il n'a jamais dit
je voudrais faire un chef-d'oeuvre
il voulait pas la préoccupation des gens
ce que les gens voulaient c'est comme ça
qu'il a réussie qui a été acceptée
disons presque instantanément
il a fait les fameuses fleurs et tu es
là quand il peint ses fameux faire alors
ses fleurs 364 il tangue rang devant un
tableau représentant ces fleurs mille
dollars et 9 ans coiffée d'un calot avec
leurs dames japy
oui ils vont me dollars dès maintenant
sa voix millions de dollars de m tu l'as
toujours cette année j'ai lu
jeune allemande a ajouté une rue en
assurant à elle n'est pas assurée à bord
sont pas le dire à la risée des films
les deux sortes de films en gros khwaja
niel estime comme ça qu'ils s'appellent
si tu vois quelqu'un dormir pendant huit
heures ou lundi un style d
il ya d'autres films avec maurice et
comme trash ou flèche place et gère plus
mis en scène comme un commercial
alors il s'est quand même fait du pognon
et ses cibles étaient fortuits les
superstars et c'est payé quoi j'étais
super star à 20 dollars par jour
on m'a dit l'autre jour je capitaliser
sur bois rouge était la veuve joyeuse
jamais gagné à volonté vous il avait le
don de nous amuser on s'amusait vous
êtes pas du tout force est d'être là et
comment jouer nous mêmes
enfin c'était quand même intéressant
même selon psychologique on faisait un
peu posséder à la sortie quand même
parce que lui c'en est non c'est à dire
que lui avait un plan un plan d'actions
- ab parle de l'été là pour pour le
l'amusement bon là au moment et lui lui
savait ce qu'il voulait enfin je lui
reproche c'est à croire aux mêmes joies
y en a qui tombe par la fenêtre et il
dit c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas une
caméra pour le film et oui enfin si
quelqu'un doit mourir
pourquoi ne pas le filmer peut-être
c'était son grand objectif puisque tu
penses comme truman capote que c'était
un sphinx en secret mais absolument
une très belle phrase est alors un jour
du crack complètement c'est la crise
c'est terrible pression une catharsis et
tu passe comme ça je sais pas combien de
temps dans ton lit tu sais où tu veux te
soigner tu veux pas tu dis que tu ne
soignera tout seul c'est assez assez
poignant quand on compte en lisant un
bouquin et là je crois que c'est
l'exorcisme qui réussit cette fois par
an
contrairement au premier un moment tu
vas voir mes parents
tu arrives dans le midi évidemment quand
on sort de la factory de chez warhol et
quand débarque dans une maison bien
bourgeoise bien française salut c'est
bien mais ça fait du bien quand on le
lit aussi c'est que j'y suis allé pour
presque leur dire au revoir je pensais
que j'allais mourir et c'est eux qui
m'ont ri société et retourné vers la
religion catholique à ce moment là non
non non non non non pas la religion
catholique mais vert
le christianisme en amérique a
énormément de religion comme tu sais
plus tôt évangélique quand on lit les et
on étudie les écritures français étudie
ultraconservateur c'est vrai je sais
bien que c'est à dire que je pense que
la lame salle des chênes que le salut ne
peut vraiment être trouvé quatre avaient
une liste de morale sami quand même
temps contre m tout ça pour moi 15 ans
je dirais je sais pas si je suis
complètement remis qu'est ce que tu
penses
je pense que tu fais
g